il y a encore deux mois cette zone était
occupée par les russes c'est ici dans
cette forêt à 10km de boudhha qu'ils
avaient établi un de leurs camps
ici où des exactions auraient été
commises sept corps de civils viennent
d'être découverts sept corps d'homme
pour certains tué d'une balle dans la
tête ils leur ont tiré dans les genoux
ce qui nous fait dire qu'ils ont été
torturés leurs mains étaient attachées
dans le dos cela indique qu'ils ont été
retenus pendant longtemps qu'ils ont
tenté de leur soutirer des informations
l'odeur est irrespirable ces hommes
auraient été tués au mois de mars et
enterrés à la hâte dans cette fosse
commune une parmi tant d'autres dans la
région de kiev 322 personnes n'ont
toujours pas été retrouvées les
recherches prennent du temps les bois
sont encore loin d'être tous des mines
et
je pense que ça va prendre des années
pour retrouver tous les corps dans la
région de kent
notre ennemi enlevé de façon très cruel
des civils seul
c'est pour ça que nous n'avons aucune
information sur eux
depuis fin mars et le retrait des
troupes russes de la région de kiev les
découvertes macabres se multiplient plus
de mille trois cent corps ont été
découverts dans des endroits comme celui
qui se trouve juste derrière moi
yauch travail pour lépine funèbre lors
de l'occupation russe les habitants des
environs faisait souvent appel à lui
quand les habitants voyait des corps il
nous appelait ici tout le monde nous
connaît
il nous disait quelqu'un a été tué vous
pouvez venir le chercher s'ils voulaient
l'enterrer qu'on pouvait on prenait un
cercueil ont récupéré le corps et on
allait l'enterrer au cimetière
l'identification des corps peut
désormais commencer une fois les
autopsier les examens réalisés ils
permettront d'alimenter les enquêtes
locales et internationales ouvertes pour
crimes de guerre